[Music]
[Music]
but state legislators voted to repeal
the law compelling the medical community
to develop new programs to increase
awareness that Eugene desperately needs
coffee the controversial law passed
nearly two years ago so we need one
Ethiopian pour over a cappuccino wet not
dry one soy latte and he's not vegan not
anymore
got it one whole latte hey Luce I'm
incapable of social interaction bummer
man I guess it's broken
here's eugene i am going to hand it off
to him so he can walk us through that
slide she'll go hi I have your attention
to look at the slide show there's so
many great things happening how to list
them all my god take a look over here
there's a lot of business things that
we're doing information you can be
yourself
excuse me for just one second
[Music]
in other news Eugene Lee yeah and
crushed an eight-year-old girls ice
cream this morning after completely
losing it in the middle of a client
meeting a new study on the migratory
path
[Music]
[Music]
then do not do a casa Papa go macapa a
perfetto
[Music]
ciao
[Music]
you